it's the 10th annual VW Bus get together
in San Power Pescador near Spain's Costa
Brava and here you can see old and new
VW buses high and low VW buses colorful
and black and white buses there are rare
and not so rare specimens somewhere high
tops and pop tops some made of rust and
some of canvas test driver mattis garage
is in his element some of these buses
have come a long way to be here today
matters came down to Spain from Germany
through France with a group of VW bus
fans and uber fan [ __ ] Nash Banyon that
was a distance of nearly 1400 kilometers
mostly on country roads there are VW
buses from the 1980s 90s and current
models but the star of the show our VW
California camper buses which turned 25
this year
VW buses are notoriously sluggish even
the turbocharged 1.6 liter diesel in the
t3 series only manages 51 kilowatts of
power and a maximum speed of 127
kilometres per hour drivers of the newer
buses here agreed to kick to this limit
as a gesture of solidarity
this time the rain in Spain fell mainly
in the mountains but only for about half
an hour I'm not enough to block the
spectacular view
volkswagen has been building campers
since the 1950s but it's become
increasingly expensive and complicated
to outfit them so the West's failures
interior was simplified and VW tossed
out many of the extras to create the
California
after nearly three days on the road our
group was getting close we crossed the
eastern Pyrenees and headed south toward
the Mediterranean
past abandoned customs houses across the
border to Spain
since it first came out in 1988 the
California has remained much the same
the first generation based on VW's t3
bus made a hit with its versatility it
was a practical workers and much more
even with the built-in kitchen it's
still slept up to four people
in the 1990s VW introduced different
versions of the team for California it
even included a built-in toilet the
first VW camper to have one
the interiors versatility and ease of
use have remained unchanged
the current generation of the VW Bus t5
has been on the road since 2003 a few
useful gadgets have been added to the
California's camping features such as
the folding chairs stowed inside the
tailgate there's lots more storage a
mini kitchen and still room to sleep for
people comfortably
inadequate edvard test driver matters
pivot assumes the VW t5 would outclassed
the other buses in almost any category
it's faster more powerful it's safer
more comfortable and takes less fuel
Abba skipped by there's one category
where he says the VW 3 California wins
hands down and that suck the cult factor
it'll take some time before even the t4
achieves that cult status the last of
the rear drive t3 VW buses were long
something of a laughingstock but now
they too have their hard core of devoted
fans
you